it's Wednesday September 14th my name is
Rob and we're talking gamespot news baby
let's get right to it if you thought we
were done with Pokemon go news for the
week think again Pokemon goes buddy
update is here downloading it will let
you choose one of your Pokemon to be
your buddy because apparently they hated
you before forcing one of your Pokemon
to be your friend earns you Candis when
you walk around with them the update
also fixes network and minor text issues
as well as a bug that would make eggs
hatch without alerting you robbing
people the ability to see their Pokemon
emerge from the shell the update also
rolls out on Pokemon go plus support the
Pokemon go plus is the small wearable
Bluetooth device that alerts you of
nearby pokey stops and helps you catch
pokemon and speaking of wearable mobile
devices following the announcement that
Pokemon go will support the Apple watch
developer niantic labs has said it's
pretty likely that the game will also be
available for Android wear devices in
the future there's a new overwatch
update out now if you were a fan of
those mercy endgame spotlights well they
just got a little dimmer yes that's
right blizzards new overwatch updates
fans across all platforms and one of the
most notable changes is that Mercy's
resurrections won't be awarded a play of
the game as frequently other notable
changes include an increased payload
speed on icon Valda a new competitive
tier legend has been added to the
competitive play info screen and a new
match complete splash screen has
replaced the former round complete
splash screen in competitive matches and
then of course your regular bug fixes
like the one that was allowing Reaper to
shadow step to unintended locations on
Hollywood call of duty infinite warfare
is just around the corner and apparently
an infinite amount of call duty games in
a marketplace interview with Blizzard
activation CEO Bobby Kotick cota talks
about the call of duty franchise and how
it will never stop shooting out titles
kodok said we've had call of duty games
played on virtually every console for
the last 14 years so the idea of having
a game that centers around armed
conflict through history you never run
out of ideas of Call of Duty games there
will always be call of duty games and
they'll be played on a variety of
devices
comments came in response to the
question on what the future looks like
for console and PC focused franchises
like Call of Duty now that smartphone
gaming is becoming so popular the exact
went on to say that Activision plans to
release games wherever the fans are well
that is all the news i found today
thanks for watching now get out there
and watch something else
you